mikael o no es avicultor desde hace 25
años como todos los días se da una
vuelta por el gallinero para verificar
que sus aves están sanas y se alimentan
bien
con mi o bien tiene el buche lleno en
una semana estos pollos negros de chalán
etiqueta roja serán puestos en el
mercado estamos con unos animales de 74
días están en la fase final entonces
tenemos un alimento con muchos cereales
trigo maíz triticale eventualmente y
además proteínas provenientes de la soya
la canola y el girasol entre otras la
soya una materia prima económica y muy
rica en proteínas
el animal la necesita durante su
crecimiento en cantidades que oscilan
entre 15 y 20 por ciento en la fase
final como ahora hay menos soya pero
sigue siendo importante tener soya para
favorecer el crecimiento del animal la
soya que mikael o no le da a sus
animales es 100% orgánica pero no 100%
francesa efectivamente la soya cultivada
en el país es poca sólo se produce en
400 mil toneladas de granos cada año
mientras se importan 23 millones de
toneladas una soya a veces es difícil de
rastrear y a menudo causante de la
deforestación se corta se quema para
sembrar un monocultivo que no servirá
para alimentar a las poblaciones humanas
sino para producir alimento para ganado
y agrocarburantes que además serán
exportados y consumidos a miles de
kilómetros
para luchar contra esta deforestación
importada el gobierno francés quiere
trasladar una parte de la producción de
las proteínas vegetales como la soya las
arvejas el trébol o incluso la alfalfa
el objetivo duplicar las superficies
consagradas a estos cultivos para 2030
lionel vogue cultiva soya desde hace
casi 40 años cada año siembra unas 50
hectáreas en su terreno pero las
semillas requieren un suelo muy seco
tuvimos muchos problemas por las lluvias
que llegaron de manera masiva en el mes
de mayo la fecha ideal es alrededor del
20 de mayo para nosotros entre el 15 y
el 20 de mayo
aquí estamos más en una siembra de
finales de mayo principios de julio pero
lo esencial está hecho este plan de
proteínas era muy esperado por los
productores de soya
y realmente necesitábamos una señal para
anclar el cultivo en la rotación de los
terrenos es decir que estuviéramos menos
sometidos a que un año se decide no
producir más soya porque no
necesariamente es el cultivo más
rentable porque está expuesta a ciertos
riesgos climáticos o porque
económicamente no tiene el mejor margen
así que el interés de la política de
acompañamiento es asegurar esa parte de
superficie de soya en la rotación de los
terrenos la rotación es el hecho de
alternar diferentes cultivos en una
misma parcela de un año al otro con el
fin de preservar la fertilidad de los
suelos y desde el punto de vista
agronómico la soya es valiosa la soya es
una leguminosa entonces es una planta
que fija el nitrógeno atmosférico así
que en términos de fertilización de la
soya es una planta muy económica además
de eso para el cultivo siguiente
restituya en el suelo un nitrógeno que
no fue necesario comprar ni producir es
un precedente excelente para los
siguientes cultivos la soya es un
cultivo que necesita pocos insumos hoy
en día no es necesario hacer
insecticidas para la soya no se
necesitan fungicidas para la soya sólo
queda la cuestión de eliminar las
malezas a base de fitosanitarios pero
también hay soluciones mecánicas para la
eliminación
esas apoyar a los agricultores es
también asegurar el conjunto del sector
la soya es transformada en una fábrica
como está el grano es triturado para
sacar el aceite por un lado y el turco
por otro este punto es el que se
encuentre la alimentación animal
patrick parras es fabricante de
alimentos a menudo se enfrenta con
dificultades de abastecimiento que
propone el plan de proteínas permitirá
reemplazar ahora una parte del déficit
que podamos tener con la importación de
la soja en particular brasileña pero
bajo ninguna circunstancia podrá
evitarse la importación de países
terceros
no es posible dadas las cantidades que
necesitamos y dadas las superficies que
sería necesario establecer en francia
será difícil ser autónomo en cuanto a la
soya en el territorio francés eso está
claro el plan de proteínas es tan sólo
una parte de la solución para de gonik
and build es necesario endurecer la
legislación sobre las importaciones
y es absolutamente necesario seguir
actuando en estos países exportadores
para asegurarse que las producciones en
esos países son sostenibles
pero efectivamente también es necesario
mejorar al mismo tiempo la autonomía
proteica de francia y también hay que
evolucionar así en menos consumo y
producción de proteínas animales
objetivo anunciado del gobierno la
soberanía alimentaria es un reto
importante actualmente el 43 por ciento
de los pollos consumidos en francia son
importados